this month the spectator becomes the
first magazine in history to print
10,000 issues and we'd like to celebrate
with you subscribe to The Spectator for
12 weeks for just 12 pounds plus we'll
send you a bottle of commemorative
spectator gin absolutely free go to
spectator code at UK forward slash
celebrate
hello and welcome to the spectators
audio reads this week is the Easter
special first we have Toby young Britain
needs you Boris
Toby young as I write Boris Johnson is
an intensive-care that's in Thomas's
hospital battling with coronavirus for
someone with such an unwavering belief
in his own destiny
this must be profoundly difficult he's a
man who's beaten the odds over and over
to become mayor of London in a Labour
City to lead the leave campaign to
victory in the teeth of overwhelming
opposition to become Prime Minister in
spite of all his personal baggage and
then to win the largest conservative
majority since 1987 here is a man who
cannot stare into the jaws of defeat
without grabbing hold of victory with
both hands yet the odds of him
triumphing in this case keep narrowing
of those who've caught the virus aged 50
to 59
Boris is 55 their chances of requiring
hospitalization are only one in 10 and
just 12 percent of that fraction end up
in intensive care a hundred to one
against and he still drawn the short
straw one sack ovid 19 patient has been
admitted to intensive care their chances
of coming out are close to 5050 it's his
sense of public duty that has landed him
in this hole people who don't know him
and even some who do talk disapprovingly
of his arrogance and vaulting ambition
but the man I've known for more than 35
years contains multitudes of which
Richard the third is only one Henry the
fifth is also in there one of his better
angels he cannot resist the pull of
obligation to his country the need to be
of service
I remember cornering him at a spectator
party shortly after he'd announced his
intention to become an MP and asking him
why he was bothering with politics when
he was so clearly destined for the top
in journalism surely being the editor of
The Telegraph would be much more fun
than shinning up the greasy pole in
Westminster a career in journalism
suited his
mischievous revelation personality
whereas he'd have to rain all that in if
he wanted to succeed in politics he
looked embarrassed he hates being asked
personal questions and muttered
something about public service it took
me a while to realize he was being
serious that must be the reason he
refused to take it easy after being
diagnosed with coronavirus in spite of
having a fever he carried on chairing
the daily Cove at 9:15 a.m. meeting and
continued going through his red boxes
some people have criticized him for not
handing over to Dominic Rob earlier as
if remaining at the helm was
irresponsible but it would have gone
against everything in Boris's nature to
hand over the wheel when navigating such
a difficult passage not while he still
had any strength left it's not a case of
refusing to acknowledge his own
vulnerability because of some misplaced
sense of exceptionalism but of carrying
on regardless out of sheer bloody-minded
duty willpower and resilience will have
just kicked in automatically I don't
suppose he gave it a second thought I've
often wondered what it must be like for
him to be Prime Minister during his
country's darkest hour since the Second
World War as I got to know him it became
clear that he saw himself as having a
historic role to play in our island
story in politics that doesn't make him
particularly unusual you'd be amazed how
many obscure backbench MPs entertained
fantasies of becoming Prime Minister
much rarer is Boris's ability to inspire
others with this belief even those who
disliked him he thought he was overrated
could never completely write him off and
those of us who've been closely
following his career watching him
fulfill his destiny came to believe it
was all wrapped up with bricks it but
winning the EU referendum and the
leadership then the election had all led
inexorably to the role he was born for
this was the pivotal moment in Britain's
history where he would Bend events to
his will and shape our future for
decades to come
and yet we were wrong or at least not
entirely right that may still be his
most important contribution but in the
meantime
evidence has something else in mind
something even more challenging I'm not
a man of faith but at moments like this
you realize you're still animated by
certain core irrational beliefs one of
those is a kind of mystical belief in
Britain's greatness and her ability to
occasionally bring forth remarkable
individuals ordinary men and women of
extraordinary ability to paraphrase
Badgett who can serve her at critical
junctures I've always thought of borås
as one of those people not just
suspected it but known it in my bones
and in spite of his shrinking odds of
survival I still cannot bring myself to
doubt Britain isn't finished with you
yet Boris you will come back to us full
of strength and vigor larger than life
like never before
you must that was Toby Young and now
Douglas Murray on what he finds
heartening about the coronavirus crisis
our flawed species still stands a chance
by Douglas Murray there was always one
key flaw in our species which is that
someone always shags a monkey I have
expressed this thought fairly regularly
in private often to friends who don't
get the reference about the likely
origin of AIDS and look at me strangely
ever after still I find it a useful rule
we humans are perhaps always have been
as weak as our weakest member makes us
and if just one of us chooses of an
evening to force themselves on one of
our simian cousins then before long
people across the planet start dropping
dead I suppose the monkey Shagga rule
will now have to be updated to take into
account the fact that someone will
always blend a bat for however developed
or progressive we fancy ourselves
however many megacities we managed to
build we will still never have 100%
certainty that there isn't someone
looking at some scrawny cave hanger and
thinking what a nice soup he would make
to contemplate these odds is to be
filled with or it seems miraculous
enough that our species can survive the
stupidity of any one human being the
idea that in order to go on we need to
survive the stupidity gluttony and I
might mention lustfulness of every human
on planet Earth
ought to put our chances that somewhere
near naught yet here we still are for
one reason alone which is that our
species also possesses a set of virtues
which with an uncanny precision
sometimes more than adequately makes up
for the rest these virtues may be dwelt
upon less often perhaps because we are
embarrassed by them perhaps because we
take them for granted or prefer our
performative negation of them but look
at the virtues this country has
demonstrated in the past several weeks
and you begin to think we might still
have a chance against the bat shaggers
throughout recent years we have read and
some of us have written constantly about
the breakdown of trust in our society
one by one the institutions that held
the public's trust were said to have
fallen whether it was the judiciary
police Parliament monarchy or anything
else a cast your mind back only a few
months and we in Britain were said to be
living in a divided country even
sometimes a failed state caught in a
crevasse between a set of competing
sources of power none of which could
command the public's trust the British
people even more than others were said
to have become distrustful of all
authority including all varieties of
expert yet here we are at Easter 2020
all cocooned more or less agreeably in
our homes faithfully obeying orders not
because we must like
population of some communist despotism
but because like citizens in democracies
worldwide we have agreed to do so if as
a result as seems possible the time of
writing the Angel of Death clips its
wings on our abode but leaves the
structure standing then there will be
plenty of gratitude for us to feel among
those sources of gratitude should be the
fact that during this time we have been
reminded beneath the din of what we
actually rely on listened to and need we
listened as the Prime Minister told us
to remain in our homes we responded when
he asked us to volunteer we were
concerned when we were told that our
National Health Service risked being
overwhelmed we were persuaded when the
nation's top scientists showed us their
graphs became household names and
persuaded us to alter our lives some
people cavil Dov course they worried
that we might have become over
subservient but that didn't seem a fair
critique certainly not in this phase the
British public did not do what we were
told because we are by nature apply' and
subservient people we did what we were
told because we believed and trusted
that a situation could have occurred
which would have left our hospitals
overwhelmed and taken our country into
disaster we acted to avert the worst of
that situation and if we have managed to
do so and end up forgetting that fact
then we'll be the lucky ones whatever
happens there is going to be mending to
do but what strikes me now is how in a
nation alleged to have been so low on
trust and respect
we have been quietly storing it away
even while we pretended otherwise when a
real problem came there wasn't much time
for the people with imaginary ones but
no stage was there a demand for
grievance studies professor
to address the nation as the virus
spread absolutely nobody called for a
press conference of social scientists we
wanted to hear from politicians clearly
trying to do their best we wanted to
hear from medical experts and finally we
wanted to hear from the queen who
remains a person best placed in our
national life or any nation's life to
put in context what will hopefully soon
recede in the national memory into one
of those ugly things that just sometimes
happens like the smog or Scots
nationalism I don't know what we'll end
up taking away from all this perhaps a
lot of things a bad financial hit
certainly and there will be other things
too perhaps there will be a knock to our
idea about the inevitability of human
progress but who knows it's ugly
to use the catastrophe as a
metastasizing force for whatever your
own political viewpoint happens to be
and of course it is possible that as a
society we take nothing away from this
that it will just be one of those
strange things like the riots in 2011
which seemed for a moment to have
changed everything but end up changing
nothing for my own part I already know
one thing I'll take which is admiration
not just for the people in this country
but for people around the world who
volunteered themselves sequestered
themselves and in some cases sacrificed
themselves not because they had no
choice but because in a moment of
terrible clarity we were all reminded of
that simple truth will corrode because
to be here means so much that was
Douglas Murray and last here's Melissa
Kate real life by Melissa kite
yeah do you want some of the private
stuff from out the back said the butcher
to the Builder boyfriend
leaning forward over the counter and
winking theatrically the Builder B
winced a little for this was starting to
feel like the terrifying scene in League
of Gentlemen
when mr. bris stopped selling a
mysterious and highly addictive special
meat to the residents of Royston Vaizey
thankfully this butcher was only selling
private lamb he revealed his secret
stash to the BB because he took a liking
to him the butcher grins revealing big
teeth between rosy cheeks before
disappearing out the back and returning
with an entire side which he butchered
in front of him offering him as much as
he wanted when he got home with the
meaty chops the BB said he had never
seen anything so funny and frightening
the butcher declared he had nothing but
contempt for the spoiled shoppers who'd
been rude to him for decades and now
came in every day complaining about the
difficulties of fulfilling their posh
recipes consequently he filled his
display cabinet with sausages bacon and
the old chicken and kept everything else
at the back he was apparently only
selling the private stuff to people he
considered working-class the Builder B
had just come off a roof which his work
he continues to do legitimately because
mending holes in buildings is essential
so far as anyone can make out dressed in
his task battered jeans steel toe cap
boots and woolly hat he must have looked
precisely the sort of worker this
butcher considered deserving and so he
is I suppose consequently he took him
into his confidence after serving him
the private stuff the butchers stiffened
as a well-dressed lady entered the shop
perused the display disdainfully and
said do not have any lamb in an
imperious tone no luck just what's Oh
bacon or sausage and he winked at the
builder B again in a most alarming
fashion I fried the shops plain and
served them with a good honest mash and
thick gravy it would have been a
betrayal of the butcher's principles to
subject them to any form of fanciful any
question they might be decorated with as
you or sat on a bed or something
middle-class like creamed spinach even
if I had the means to do such a thing
which I didn't really was taking the
proverbial and we want to keep our mr.
bris happy the queue at the farm shop is
now right across the pebble drive
towards the field that's the overflow
car part in another week the queue might
be all the way around that field over
the fence across the road and into the
field where they seized the 123 horses
last year it seems an age since that
happened a lot of the folks who rang
that messy old place into the
authorities may soon be wishing they
hadn't had those big fat cobs removed
because they were standing in mud the
trial of the farmer who owns the herd of
horses was postponed a few weeks ago as
several lawyers in the courtroom fell
sick where the horses are and how long
they can be kept going in the current
climate is anyone's guess the farm is
now covered in a hundred acres of grass
they might have been grazing and a barn
stacked to the rafters with hay but the
irony of that seems lost on most local
people not the man who runs the garden
center he was helping put deliveries
together running backwards and forwards
ranting about greed much like the
butcher he had come to his own moral
conclusions and was prioritizing old
people I mentioned the horse seizure
seeming like another era and he agreed
there are fine upstanding individuals in
this society of ours who would eat your
cat as soon as look at it I see where
he's coming from but I'm not so sure I
fear the opposite the people have been
pampered so long they are not prepared
to tap into their instincts to survive
the bee bee however points out there is
an awful lot of vegan food left on the
shelves and stores that are otherwise
empty could it be that when push comes
to shove the dalts practicing food
faddish nurse will revert to eating what
nature truly intended perhaps it was
only when there was an endless supply of
everything that the vegan you Eric ride
are happy to opt for an allegedly
cruelty-free environmentally sustainable
food source in the name of doing
something a bit different
maybe now general survival is coming
into question they will be grateful for
any meat and cheese they can get as the
free from ranges molder on the show
that was Melissa kite thanks for
listening and join us again next week
you